l'ombre de françois mitterrand plane sur
ce procès depuis le début tous les
prévenus ont reconnu avoir agi sur ordre
de l'elysée
le document visionner ce matin
l'audience est édifiant il s'agit d'une
interview réalisée par une équipe de la
télévision belge
la seule à avoir osé interroger le
président sur les errements des visées
l'écoutera ria nouveau quantité système
d'éco ici le système des côtes il est il
dépend du premier ministre et
physiquement je crois même pas vous le
garantir je sais pas où c'est je crois
qu'il filmait le départ lewis à la
défense il s'agissait des coups qui ont
été commandés par la cellule
antiterroriste de l'elysée bien sûr pas
on sent encore un peu plus au bout de la
quatrième question des journalistes
belges à propos des écoutes viennent le
président perd patience
le demander justement si la de décorer
une super auto navette est terminée
le préfet photo qui dirigeait la cellule
confirme aujourd'hui qu'il avait toute
latitude pour mettre des dizaines de
personnalités sur l'équipe dans quelles
conditions le comment j'ai fait ça je
pense que pour lui ça posait pas de
problème sinon il n'aurait pas continué
à me recevoir jusqu'à la fin puisque je
les ai vu pratiquement trois semaines
avant son décès à l'époque un des hommes
les plus dérangeants pour françois
mitterrand puis sans aucun doute edwy
plenel journaliste au monde et il fut
avec jean edern hallier le plus écouté
cet homme a abusé de l'autorité de
l'état pour protéger ses propres secrets
privé et d'un coup du coup il a laissé
violer la vie privée de toutes sortes de
personnes de toutes sortes d'individus
par unique chiche mission politique le
réquisitoire de ce procès fleuve sera
prononcée dans le courant la semaine
prochaine